[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 les invités une
émission dédiée à celles et ceux qui
font l'actualité dans le département est
aujourd'hui mercredi 10 mai parole a
notamment fanny poli chargé de mission
pour la compagnie nomade une compagnie à
la base de la première édition du
festival culture et sports urbains qui
se déroule jusqu'au 20 mai à
vélizy-villacoublay nous évoquerons avec
elle est un artiste aussi le programme
de l'événement et ses ambitions parole
aussi dans cette émission à françois
ellis directeur d' agences immobilières
sur l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines il nous présentera l'état des
lieux du marché immobilier sur le
territoire et nous dira aussi si celui
ci est toujours attractif
fanny poule fanny poli excusez moi et
françois à thourotte bonsoir à tous les
deux mon sort vous étiez respectivement
chargé de mission pour la compagnie
nomade ça c'est fanny poli et puis
artiste graffeur graffiti c'est pour
vous ça françois tout rhodes
on va parler avec vous du coup de la
première édition du festival sports et
cultures urbaines qui se tient jusqu'au
20 mai à vélizy villacoublay
je vais commencer avec vos fans
hippolyte déjà par vous commencez une
question sur la génèse de cette première
puisque c'est une première fois sur le
territoire que vous organisez ça en
compagnie avec de la mairie en
partenariat avec la mairie comment s'est
passée la mise en place de ce festival
qui en est l'initiateur
alors l'initiateur donc c'est donc c'est
la médiathèque la mairie de vélizy
villacoublay qui a vu donc une action de
la compagnie nomade l'année dernière à
clamart qui était donc c'était un petit
festival aussi donc culture et sports
urbains
ça leur a plu donc ils ont contacté
mehdi slimani et le chorégraphe qui
l'aura qui leur a dit oui qu'il était
partant et du coup ça s'est passé comme
ça telle est l'idée de ce festival quels
sont les objectifs peut-être les choses
que vous souhaitez mettre en avant pour
les plus jeunes aussi et puis pour pour
la ville de vélizy villacoublay belle et
les sensibiliser à l'art à la culture
surtout la culture urbaine qui est une
nouvelle culture qui peut les intéresser
ce sont des cultures et des sports
urbains qui sont encore trop peu on va
dire trop trop peu connu aujourd'hui en
france et pas assez mis en avant aussi
la de plus en plus il ya de plus en plus
de festivals qui se créent dans cette
dynamique et le but et oui c'est
sensibiliser les jeunes
alors j'ai noté que l'intitulé du
festival c'était culture et sports
urbains tout ça au plus rien alors pour
sport urbain on peut comprendre que ce
soit au pluriel culture c'est peut-être
quelque chose qu'on ne sait pas mais ce
n'est pas un monde j'ai envie de dire
homogène il ya différentes cultures au
sein du monde urbain ce que vous pouvez
peut-être nous expliquer ça enfin en
tout cas il y aura plusieurs choses
notamment du graff
on va en parler ça sont au programme
vous êtes là pour soi françois à
thourotte est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer sur les stages qu'il y aura qu
est ce que vous allez faire autour de ce
stage alors le principe du festival
c'est d'avoir des ateliers en parallèle
en plus de démonstrations de
professionnels comme la battle où on
sensibilise les jeunes à différentes
activités dont la le graff ou le but va
être de décorer une partie de la
médiathèque avec les jeunes s'y
connaissent pas forcément voilà ce que
vous serez toujours là pour les encadrer
c'est ça l'idée c'est jean cadre sérieux
je fais une initiation concernant
l'historique les techniques du graffiti
comment réalisent une fresque de a à z
et dans l'idée c'est de prendre leurs
idées faire un petit multicoque une mise
en commun pour réaliser une décoration
qui sera définitive quoi qui reste à la
médiathèque puis aussi montrée peut-être
que le gars malgré certaines idées
reçues c'est pas uniquement et c'est pas
du tout même puisque c'est un art à part
entière des dégradations c'est un vrai
avec ses codes ses pratiques c'est voilà
c'est ça sert que le les gens ont
tendance à voir ce qu'on voit dans la
rue les voies ferrées attendant le
tramway
voilà et depuis toujours on développe le
côté artistique du graffiti mais souvent
dans des terrains vagues des usines
désaffectées des lieux où les gens vont
pas oser sauter une barrière ou passés
dans des endroits un peu spéciaux pour
venir voir mais où là on réalise des
fresques des fois sur une semaine quinze
jours voire plus et où il ya un vrai
travail artistique sur la médiathèque de
vélizy-villacoublay qu'est ce que vous
allez faire vous savez déjà ce que vous
allez faire tout est déjà en place
lorsqu'on croit découvrir d'ici une
dizaine de jours maintenant
alors on a fait la première sens
aujourd'hui l'idée c'était de mélanger
le thème des cultures urbaines et vu que
c'est une médiathèque et c'est la salle
informatique et les jeux vidéo donc on
va faire un petit mélange de tout ça
c'est à dire être présenté sous forme de
jeux vidéo au niveau visuel les
différentes activités et surtout l'idée
là c'est qu'on est parti sue suis parti
sur l'idée des jeunes chacun selon ce
qu'ils voulaient faire et pouvoir faire
une composition d'après leurs idées sur
ce thème ça se passe bien avec les
jeunes ça s'est bien passé car êtes
habitué je crois ouais mais ça fait des
années que je fais ça fait trente ans
que je peins et ça fait à peu près vingt
ans que j'encadre des décors s'appelle
des groupes de toutes tranches d'âge
donc faut juste s'adapter un peu au
projet en lui-même en général ça se
passe bien juste pour évoquer un peu
votre parcours on disait que le graff
c'est un art vous êtes vous mêmes
exposées comme n'importe quels artistes
peintres sculpteurs ou autre vous êtes
souvent exposé la zup moi j'ai commencéà
graphique et en 88
en gros j'ai commencé à faire des toiles
des 91 et des expositions
93 mais aujourd'hui les clips dans des
voilages et travail que ce soit pour le
cinéma la télé nous des expositions j'ai
soixante dix expositions à mon actif des
performances et plein de choses dans les
médias qui sont artistes connus et
reconnus et il y en aura d'autres pour
ce stage jusqu'au 20 mai quelques
quelques noms comme ça paul eric je suis
un pion du monde 2005 de hip hop le dj a
flight aussi qui est on va dire entre
guillemets titre et je ne sais pas si on
peut dire titre et pour le monde des dj
ça a été facile que les de les faire
venir de les convaincre c'est eux-mêmes
ils sont et se sont manifestés comme ça
s'est passé
oui c'est c'était assez simple tout le
monde se connaît plus ou moins donc
c'était ouest très facile de les avoir
il était super motivé aussi vous pouvez
nous parler éventuellement d'une d'une
initiation que je ne connaissais pas du
tout le double dutch
je sais pas si je prononce bien le nom
c'est une discipline un grossièrement
qui combine breakdance acrobaties et
corde à sauter vu comme ça ça peut
peut-être paraître impressionnant mais
c'est ouvert à tout le monde
concrètement il faut déjà être un bon
sportif non faire d'une zone de la tout
à l'heure on allait on allait récupérer
des jeunes qui étaient sur le skatepark
pour les justement les motiver à venir
et
il était tout de suite très très très
motivés par ça et c'est double corde à
sauter c'est très sportif mais c'est
accessible à tout le monde dirait que ça
a l'air compliqué mais en fait pas
forcément enfin faut peut-être insisté
là dessus que ça peut faire peur quand
on n'a peut-être jamais touché à une
bombe
quand on n'a jamais de fait une corde à
sauter mais c'est accessible à tout le
monde tout le monde peut s'y mettre et
façon il faut c'est bête à dire mais il
faut commencer quelque part c'est ça
l'idée c'est ça aussi
par exemple pour le graffiti il n'y a
pas d'endroit prévu pour donc c'est bien
d'avoir des initiatives comme ça d'
ateliers où les gens peuvent essayer et
se rendre compte que c'est pas si facile
que ça et d'avoir un espace prévu pour
ça développer le cnnic le temps fort de
ce festival le point d'orgue j'avais
dire ça sera le 20 mai avec la battle
duo mythique
vous y serez notamment présents je crois
le point d'orgue du festival
je prends un piano pour le pendant la
bataille fait d'accord et justement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer un
peu cette battle en quoi ça consiste
et puis on peut nous expliquer son
poisson son importance dans le monde de
la battle en ile de france notamment
lors son principe il est simple donc
c'est des équipes de deux personnes qui
s'affrontent donc comme une compétition
avec les huitièmes de finale jusqu'à la
finale où il ya une récompense de 2 600
euros pour les finalistes et mais le but
c'est
c'est la danse et c'est j'ai perdu le
début de la question non c'était juste
que vous nous expliquer la battle voulez
savoir notamment la s'est ouvert au
public aussi où ces circonscriptions
lancé vers tout public tout public sur
inscription
et donc ça sera le 20 mai on peut
s'inscrire notamment via le site
internet de la ville et la médiathèque
les stages de graffitis petite question
là aussi sans qu on verrait encore et
encore des places il réagit comme les
jeunes aujourd'hui on 5,5 gens cinq
jeunes et il ya encore trop de séances
de séance voilà donc le stage c'est
jusqu'au 20 mai et l'ensemble de ces
sachets à la médiathèque notamment pour
le graff familier et le 20 mai pour la
battle duo mythique à laquelle il faut
assister c'est l'occasion de voir des
danseurs venus de toute l'ile-de-france
un fil des français ça donc c'est une
chance importante c'est le samedi 20 mai
après midi au skatepark de vélizy avenue
de l'europe
merci à vous deux est revenue en plateau
on peut retrouver plus d'informations
notamment sur le site atteint de la
ville de vélizy ou sur votre nom sur
votre site internet avant d' injuste
avait à taper sur google nomades
compagnie merci à vous et puis bon
festival merci à l'accueil on poursuit
cette émission avec un tout autre sujet
et un focus sur le marché immobilier de
la saint quentin en yvelines un
territoire de plus en plus attractif et
plusieurs facteurs favori ce phénomène
les explications avec françois élise
directeur d' agences immobilières sur
l'agglomération au micro de nicolas
d'andré vous pourrez tous les
territoires et 50 ans
en quoi le territoire 50 attractif pour
que les gens qui arrêtent alors
attractif pour différentes raisons bien
évidemment la première va être un accès
sur paris qui est relativement proche
avec la gare rer on peut être très
rapidement donc on a une forte demande
de clients qui vont vous dire du 92 de
paris pour l'axé proche de paris on a
également un accès sur le côté
économique où de nombreux chefs
d'entreprise sont présents sur montrent
unis pour ne pas en citer quelques-uns
vous avez mercedes renault
vous avez bouygues donc un grand nombre
d'entreprises tant sur le secteur dont
beaucoup de mutations internes de gens
qui viennent ici est un attrait
également sur le côté environnement du
secteur la vallée de chevreuse qui est à
deux pas un secteur très très calme très
agréable beaucoup d espaces verts à une
ville une ville nouvelle
on a essentiellement d
une clientèle de cadres ingénieurs la
moyenne ça va être entre 25 et 40 ans
une grande partie vient de faire leurs
premières achat sur montigny où elle en
cours et ont différents critères que
l'on étudie bien évidemment avec eux des
critères de surface d'environnement
d'emplacements est de plus en plus sur
un aspect également économique ou de
plus en plus de nos clients vous
regardez sur un logement va être plus ou
moins énergivore donc avec ça on a
différentes diagnostic qui sont mis en
place notamment ce qu'on appelle le dpe
le diagnostic de performance énergétique
ou là un expert va analyser le logement
pour voir s'il consomme plus ou moins
d'énergie qui va se baser sur différents
critères
les consommations énergétiques réelles
dans la vraie facture edf ou gdf mais
aussi le type de fenêtre utile de
radiateur si on a des voisins au dessus
ou en dessous pour cet aspect économique
écologique va être important pour nos
clients qu'on a ces deux typologies on a
une grande majorité de clients qui sont
déjà sur le secteur mais qui veulent
faire ce qu'on appelle des opérations
palier qui on a deux pièces qui vont
vouloir acheter un quatre pièces ou pas
cet appartement à la maison non vraiment
on passe d'une échelle à une autre et
une deuxième partie de notre clientèle
va venir des départements limitrophes et
qui vont pas forcément pouvoir s'acheter
une maison un appartement dans le 92 au
sort paris et vont s'expatrier un petit
peu en banlieue sur la banlieue ouest
qui la banlieue une des plus beaux et
des plus réputés et les plus tranquilles
et le plus agréable et avec donc l'axé
rer très rapide sur l'année 2016 sur nos
deux agences publiques nous a fait nous
avons fait plus de 120 vente ce qui nous
fait une vente pour les deux jours donc
c'est un secteur qui est relativement
dynamique
il ya un turnover qui assez important
m'ont beaucoup de gens viennent
viennent et vont sur le secteur de
montigny elancourt c'est la fin de ce
set 8 les invités pour ce soir prochain
rendez vous demain même heure d'ici là
retrouvez toutes nos séquences sur notre
site internet tv fil 78 points comme ou
l'application aux tv fil 78 excellente
soirée à tous et à demain
[Musique]